[Musique]
mais bon jour mais bonjour monsieur je
vous cueille au réveil comme ça qu'on se
sustente parce que j'en ai va être très
très longues ouais ça fait toujours
bizarre de dire aux gens je n'évacue
longuet a fait nous voir avec des
palmiers c'est vrai les gens ne sont pas
prêts non mais nous ne voulions plus
relève après ça n'est pas notre vis une
vie d'en prendre le car noël que jours
par an pour prendre un autre et on est
heureux aussi on est très heureux mais
on est très très heureux et moi je suis
heureux et re étape tête heurtant si moi
je suis très tôt moi je me perds tu
aurais aussi de sonia commencer les
vidéos à contre-jour comme ça avec le
soleil derrière aujourd'hui où est ce
que je vous emmène aujourd'hui je vous
emmène à hawaï ouais c'est vrai qu'on va
pas tous les jours à white est là
aujourd'hui on va à wye pour parler de
qui on va parler de qualcomm
[Musique]
est ce que le spot est pas ouf les
initiés regardez vous aimez l'océan
derrière notre soleil on a les palmiers
bref on est plutôt pas mal je vous
emmène aujourd'hui en plein mois de
décembre c'est vachement bien ouais pour
parler de quoi pour parler du nouveau
processeur de pâles comme qui va arriver
début 2022 alors je sais pas si vous le
savez on revient pas en arrière 2019 je
vous avais des gens les découvrir ce
qu'allait être le cendre agon 865 qui
était la plus la plus performante de
l'année 2020 l'année dernière on n'a pas
pu déplacer vous le savez à cause de
quoi que des copies bien évidemment on
appelait ça commence tout doucement à
prendre et ça c'est vachement bien
qu'aujourd'hui on se parle de la
nouvelle puce de qualcomm qui va être a
priori jeu mais prend vraiment des
guillemets parce que ça devrait être en
tout cas la plus la plus performante de
l'année 2022 il faut voir ce qui se
passe du côté de chez mediatek parce
qu'ils ont c'est un dilemme sit-in 9000
qui a d'être aussi plutôt pas mal ici on
est une puce qui est gravé en quatre
anneaux mais je vais tout vous expliquer
à commencer par un changement de nom
[Musique]
ils aiment bien nous faire une petite
blague chez qualcomm changement non
alors avant si vous vous souvenez on est
dans la série glee la série 8 c'est quoi
c'est la série de la performance la plus
haute performance chez qualcomm on avait
le 8 135 1 855 le
865 le 888 l'année dernière et l'on se
retrouve avec un nouveau nom c'est un
dragon 8 donc la série huit gènes one
première génération donc ça montre ce
qui va arriver dans les années suivant
c'est-à-dire un gentoo engine 3 j'arrive
à comprendre le changement de
dénomination de ce constat un peu moins
sexy et un petit peu moins d' aventure
au niveau du nom ça en tout cas c'est
pour changement est ce qui est super
intéressant c'est que on sait déjà quel
va être le premier smartphone à être
équipée du snapdragon 8 jonone je vais y
arriver je me faire à l'appellation que
c'est le chien au 1012 service donc ça
veut dire qu'on aura plusieurs chez au
1012 alors on l'avait vu déjà l'année
dernière on devrait avoir le chai au
1012 monsieur omis douce prolé schumi 12
ultra avoir ce qu'on aura en france
parce que l'année dernière si vous
souvenez sur le mieux on n'avait pas de
me once cros on l'a vu sur le mythe 10
on avait uniquement un million ultra on
verra en tout cas ça début d'année
prochaine on vous invite dès maintenant
à venir vous inscrire ce n'est pas déjà
fait vous cliquez sur le petit bouton
rouge il est rouge il est juste là si
vous n'êtes pas inscrit eh bien il faut
le faire vous activer la cloche comme ça
vous serez notifié dès qu une prochaine
vidéo arrivera et ça c'est vachement
bien
[Musique]
ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui si c'est
dresser le portrait robot du smartphone
le plus performant en théorie de l'année
2022 on va voir jusqu'où on peut aller
en termes de performances on va se baser
vraiment se rend compte et fiches
techniques ans avec un peu tech mais on
va essayer de dégrossir tout ça est
d'expliquer tout savoir jusqu'où on va
pouvoir aller au niveau de nos écrans au
niveau de l'audio il ya pas mal de
choses qui nous ont été données par
qualcomm c'est extrêmement intéressant
alors c'est vraiment très technique donc
ça reste vrai ont conditionné à la puce
soc snapdragon 8 jane wan jen hommes
première génération comme on veut que ça
va dépendre bien évidemment des choix du
constructeur on va voir jusqu'où on peut
aller mais vous allez voir en tout cas
c'est vachement intéressant et si vous
vous posez la question à quoi va
ressembler le smartphone le plus
performant de 2022 et bien sûr voire 90
de répliques
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qu'on a ici on a un soc
tegra vais en 4 nanomètres qui va être
20 % plus rapide et qui vous permettra
d'avoir 30 % d'autonomie en plus par
rapport à la génération précédente la
cpu qui va cadencé jusqu'à 3 giga hertz
et au niveau de la rame ce sera de
l'ipad et des recettes 3200 mais guerre
et on pourra monter jusqu'à 16 giga
watts à ses côtés performances pures à
des usages est extrêmement fort c'est le
gaming est lent mais sûr l'arrêter ce
qui se passe du côté du gpu on a bien
évidemment une adreno on va être 30 %
plus rapide que la génération précédente
et qui lui permettra d'avoir 25 %
d'autonomie en plus on aura également de
l'intelligence artificielle ici c'est
l'intelligence artificielle de septième
génération alors vous me direz on s'en
fiche un petit peu de connaître le
nombre de générations mais on devrait
aller quatre fois plus vite par rapport
à la génération précédente il ya un truc
qui est super intéressant c'est toute la
partie connectivité 5g wifi alors on va
retrouver ici du wifi c'est du wifi 6 et
du wifi 6e va dépendre des normes qu'on
va avoir nous en france me fit si c'est
sur wii fit 6e à venir on va aller
jusqu'à 3,6 gigabit surtout vous avez le
modem c'est le x 65 5 g qui vous
permettra d'aller jusqu'à 10 gigabits
par seconde en théorie avoir ce qu'il
faut derrière c'est que les opérateurs
envoie la sauce il faut vous y un
abonnement qui envoie la sauce mais en
tout cas ici le nouveau sa dragonne 8
jean one permettra d'aller jusqu'à 10
gigabits par seconde sans papiers c'est
cool on se parlait site 5g ondes
millimétriques et subsea stunden sur de
la multi sim et sur toutes les bandes 5
g existe entre un ex alors ça ça va être
intéressant pour les usages gaming si
vous voulez jouer dans la rue en
déplacement essayer ça vous allez avoir
des connexions qui vont aller beaucoup
plus vite mais une fois de plus ça va
dépendre des abonnements ça va dépendre
des opérateurs s'ils ouvrent les vannes
oui ou non mais ce qui est sûr en tout
cas sur le papier c'est qu'avec le wifi
6e en tout cas wifi 6 en france chez
vous et bien ça devrait être tartiner ça
devrait aller plutôt pas mal c'est
qu'elles sont louis fils rapport à ce
que vous avez actuellement pas sûr qu'il
ya un énorme changement à voix et sur la
5g une fois de plus et opérateur
indépendant et réseau défendre
[Musique]
je dirais qu un des sujets que nous
intéressait le plus c'est toute la
partie photo vidéo face à des usages les
plus vieilles courant sur smartphone
pour rester dans le très concret ici on
a le 18 à espira esprits ces images
signal processor 18 versus 14 bon ça
reste très très technique on t'en fous
des chiffres ce qu'il faut retenir et si
c'est qu'on va pouvoir capter 4 mille
fois plus de data en photo versus la
génération précédente aura 3,2
gigapixels par seconde et évidemment des
photos 10 bits sans doute règne des
photos nues qui vont être améliorées
elles vont être cinq fois meilleur en
photo nuit enfin le secours mirta en
face comme d'apprendre trente clichés
différentes attaques à coup sûr les
expos long 30 photos différentes ils
vont venir les superposer on vous
proposer la meilleure photo pour venir
tout exposé correctement bon bref y'a
plus de capacités de calcul on pourra en
faire plus ça ça paraît logique on a en
plus dû always zone high speed niveau du
images signal processeur c'est votre
appareil photo sera toujours activé vous
le prenez vous appuyez vous déclenchez
sa part tout de suite vous n'avez pas
besoin de venir d'allumer l'application
essayer ça et tout ça sans dépense
d'énergie supplémentaire vous allez
également avoir une accélération une
amélioration au niveau de la
reconnaissance des scènes et au niveau
du focus de l'image est évidemment plus
de performances plus de capacités de
calcul la plus vite donc on a un vrai
gain d'efficacité et au niveau des
photos pourra monter jusqu'à 200
mégapixels sur une seule caméra je goûte
je sus il fait une chaleur absolument
incroyable si vous avez aux trois
capteurs d'activer en même temps vous
pourrez faire simultanément des photos
en 36 mégapixels alors je ne sais pas
sûr que vous cherchez à faire des photos
entre hans et mégapixels mais on peut
réfléchir vauriac des usages un peu
sympa vous avez déclenché en même temps
avec le téléobjectif avec le grand angle
avec l' ultra grand angle si en plus
derrière votre smartphone est capable
d'interpréter tout ça pour en sortir une
super photo ça peut être assez rigolo
une fois de plus avoir les usages ici on
vous montre qu'on peut faire au maximum
et on verra après de quelle façon les
constructeurs vont venir intégrer tout
ça pour proposer des solutions
logicielles vraiment intéressantes et
pertinentes alors jusqu'où on va pouvoir
aller en terme de vidéo on voit que
c'est un peu le parent pauvre la vidéo
il ya une très gros focus fait sur la
photo est en règle générale la vidéo
c'était pas ouf pas ou pas ouf même si
aujourd'hui il ya d'excellents
smartphones qui font de la vidéo on
espère que ça va commencer à se
développer on le voit de plus en plus il
ya des besoins que les différents
réseaux sociaux ont fait de la vidéo
rapide que ce soit tic toc et compagnie
donc on a des besoins en terme de vidéo
ici on pourra venir filmer jusqu'à huit
cas hdr à 30 images par seconde en 4k à
120 images par seconde du super slow
motion en 720p à 960 images par seconde
on pourra faire également de la vidéo
bloqués dont j'ai vu passer des choses
ça me transcende pas des masses dans la
vidéo boké vous savez vous avez votre
vidéo puis vous avez un flou générer
artificiellement de ce que j'ai vu ça ne
paraît pas dingue on verra effectivement
ce qui va se passer en 2022 là-dessus à
voir si c'est intéressant et si c'est
pertinent la vidéo dit [ __ ] hdr 10 plus
hdr disent on va être en règle 2020
comme ça on a jusqu'au bout vous saurez
tout hlg dolby vision
[Musique]
est ce que ça raconte au niveau de
l'écran alors au niveau de l'écran on
pourra monter jusqu'à qhd plus en 144 r
c'est vrai qu'il ya déjà aujourd'hui des
smartphones qui vous propose du 144 us
mais petit plus on du crédit plus police
vérifie je sais plus et vous et pour
monter jusqu en 4k à 60 hertz passant
merde c'est si par contre vous aurez des
couleurs débit très du hcr et du ageris
plus et ça c'est cool alors bientôt qui
se passe aussi au niveau de l'audio et
c'est intéressant et nous on fait une
petite démo sur ce qu'ils appellent le
snapdragon semble qu'on devrait aussi
pouvoir vous trouvez au niveau de
smartphones qu'est ce que ça raconte se
scindera gang cendres ça nous permet
d'avoir de la ptx loge l'est loseless
l'os laisse lossless qu'est ce que ça
vous permet d'avoir ça eh bien ça vous
permet d'avoir de la ptx sans perte de
qualité c'est comme si vous aviez une
qualité cd sans perte de signal sans
perte de qualité alors c'est vrai qu'ils
nous ont fait une démo ici où on écoute
un petit peu ce boulot nesta ptx le leff
lossless novès elmo ssl e2s voilà comme
ça vous l'avez vous l'avez sans fil donc
ça c'est plutôt cool ils nous ont fait
une démo on l'écouté sur des enceintes
avec de l'autre côté ce que vous allez
avoir avec un codec sb c'est ce que vous
avec votre collègue a pété x lossless
c'est pas trop rendu compte dans une
grande salle comme ça on nous fait
écouter la différence se signale perdu
mais c'est vrai que c'est extrêmement
compliqué de se rendre compte de la
différence sur le principe tout ça
intéressant à voir à tester plus tard
bien évidemment par soi même mais dans
l'idée pourquoi par tout en sachant
qu'ici voulait pas monter jusqu en
bluetooth 5.2 également du bluetooth est
le la aux énergies ok ça c'est pour le
yacht
[Musique]
pour se parler d'audio regarder on va
les voir quelqu'un pour soi a dit dans
un bon soir vision d'horreur
comment ça va ou bien là mon pépé
comment vous allez les gens bas ils vont
bien je crois c'est super cool que tu
sois là moi c'est toi qui est super
content d'être là mon pépé dis moi j'ai
une question on parle d' effectivement
d'audio sur le nouveau stade ragots 8
jeannet épée réveille-toi pp
on nous parle de snapdragon sang dont on
nous parle aussi de à péter x loos lez
béthune où on s'est un peu tout ça alors
le truc c'est que ça normalement que
quoi comme travail sur le son c'est pas
une nouveauté sa femme en qui se
travaille sur l'appétit ont acheté la
licence à péter eastgate ont créé il
travaille sur un meilleur débit au
niveau de l'audio bluetooth donc ce
qu'est d'entre votre smartphone et vos
écouteurs vos casques et autres et là
ils vont faire évoluer leur écosystème
avec pour la première fois au monde pour
eux la possibilité d'avoir exactement la
même qualité la qualité cd est
exactement la même ce smartphone et à
l'arrivée c'est à dire sur un casque qui
serait compatible à péter exploit se
laisse donc on aurait le la qualité cd
plein pot ça veut dire qu'on fait sur
une source est née dès le départ ça
serait pas le son de secret par il faut
qu'on ait une source qualité cd la corde
sur le smartphone il va l'envoyer en
bleu tous au travers du codec apt et
xbox live et que de l'autre côté il y un
récepteur émetteur récepteur d'un
protocole complet donc si on a les deux
on a une qualité une qualité cd de côté
l'idée de base la part des ingénieurs
avec qui on a parlé tous les deux c'est
de se dire on aura la même qualité que
ce soit en fils ou en bluetooth avec le
protocole a pété x lossless le truc on
les sert à en 2022 puisqu'il ya des
smartphones qui arriveront équipés et
pendant il n'y a pas de dette pas
d'écouteurs n'ya pas d'un trail a pas de
casque qui sont compatibles ça va venir
mais d'ici là je te laisse te rend bien
oui j'étais content de te parler parler
à tes petits loulous
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on voit ici c'est à dire on
est un peu le portrait robot qui se
dressent du smartphone le plus
performant de l'année 2022 alors bien
évidemment roux va suivre sans regarder
ce que propose aussi médiathèque on va
tester ya les benchmark on va suivre on
va regarder moi ce qui m'intéresse ici
c'est de voir les évolutions on va avoir
notamment au niveau de la photo vous
avez la tondeuse derrière qui fait un
petit peu oui c'est vraiment ça les
émotions qui va être intéressante c'est
la faute aux voix ce qu'on est capable
de sortir aussi en terme de qualité
vidéo voir jusqu'où on va aller au
niveau de la photo de nuit bien
évidemment testé toute l'expérience
gaming avec ce nouveau processeur qui va
apporter plus de performance dont c'est
surtout un usage est extrêmement
important aujourd'hui le gaming donc
voir réellement jusqu'où on va aller ici
on dresse la fiche technique on voit
jusqu'où va aller le smartphone le plus
performant de l'année 2022 et maintenant
ce qu'il reste à voir rester extrêmement
important c'est de quelle manière les
constructeurs vont utiliser les
performances délivrées par cette
nouvelle puce sa dragonne 8 jean one
vous proposer des smartphones
intéressant surtout des smartphones
différents en fonction de chaque
constructeur tout ça on le regardera
bien évidemment en 2022 donc une fois de
plus jamais tenir vous abonnez vous
cliquez et là il ya la tondeuse ce qui
est en train de tourner si je peux faire
tondre et bien je vous laisse alors je
vous embrasse pour lé soin de vous et à
très bientôt pour un mois je veux les
payer ce soir mais ça c'est bien ça
c'est cool libye lucho
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]